today I want to discuss one thing that
just might be making you totally
miserable even though you're completely
unaware but welcome to Table Talk where
each week I unpack ideas and insights at
the intersection of Christian theology
and culture with the goal of helping you
become a more thoughtful calm and just a
downright great human being my name is
Brett silvered pastor at the table at
church in Sachse Texas and this is table
talk episode number 31 so this video is
being posted in a very late April and
that means we're over a month five weeks
six weeks I don't know what it's been
but basically into the shelter and place
orders in light of the coronavirus and
and all that and so not surprisingly
there are many of us struggling with
really challenging negative emotions we
feel anxious we feel afraid perhaps we
even feel just fresh created or just
flat-out angry and like many of you I am
far from unfamiliar with these types of
emotions and so I've been asking myself
the question what's at the root of them
like where are they coming from and as I
discussed in my last video I think some
of them are stemming from the process of
grief however I've noticed another
source as well it feels to me like so
many important things are out of my
control of course some level this is
always true but there's something about
like this moment that makes me feel it
so deep in my bones I think the the key
phrase in the statement I just made is
is the important things it's sort of
like a parent watching their kids grow
up and you know you have to learn to let
them go and as long as the decisions
they're making are small decisions like
will they choose to drink the apple
juice or the orange juice today will
they wear the blue shorts of the green
shorts well you know we can deal with
giving them control even if they choose
the you know the green shorts and we
prefer the blue
a we're laid-back you can let others
make decisions but but what happens when
those kids grow up and now they're
making not small decisions now they're
making big decisions in what we would
call important decisions decisions that
could have ripple effects for them and
us for the rest of our lives all of a
sudden something rises up in us and we
begin trying to control them and what I
want to name is that at a county a state
a country in much less a global level we
and our leaders are no longer picking
between blue shorts and green shorts but
but we have circumstances facing us that
are a really big deal how do we shelter
in place for how long what should be the
timing and strategy for ending the
shelter in place what voices do we trust
or not trust in this time and then we
get the anxiety inducing process of
watching our leaders make these
decisions often in our opinions poorly
in real time now quick footnote for
anyone who follows me on social media
you probably know my position on all
this I think the folks who want to open
up the country before we are able to
test millions of people per day are
being foolish and naive I think we need
to follow the lead of countries like
Singapore and have massive testing and
tracing systems in place ASAP and then
we can open up but all right that's not
the point of this video
in footnote all right so there go our
leaders making decisions on our behalf
and something rises up in us and we long
to control them we long to have a say we
long to make them do the right thing you
know our thing but but you know what the
reality is while we may be able to have
like some small influence on the people
around us perhaps even some influence
that like the state or national level
you know my calling or email
elected officials are signing a petition
sharing a post on Facebook or something
you know at the end of the day we don't
get to control them we don't get to
think for them we don't get to guide
their hands as they sign certain
executive orders we are not in control
again
am I saying we literally can't do
anything no but face it are other people
largely out of our control yes yes they
are you see this is one of those things
that that we know but we don't want to
admit and so our minds just keep
churning on the problem thinking that
there's something there's something I
can do there's there's something I can
say there's some way I can fully control
this outcome I know it I just know it my
friend you and I are not gods we are
mere human beings and although we try to
ignore this fact and although we try to
tell ourselves otherwise we're actually
being delusional we're not in control
all right so what can we do let me give
you two suggestions number one let it go
stop trying to control everything and
everyone relax your rigidity is not
helping it's not helping your health and
it's not helping your peace or anxiety
levels instead accept it fully down to
your toes you are not in control you
don't get to choose what articles people
share on Facebook much less what the
government does take a deep breath
chill out find your peace again return
to God again second love and lead well
in the sphere God has given you you see
although on a county state national
global level you and I have very little
control in your little world how you
choose to deal with this is in fact true
impactful for the the five ten twenty
maybe a hundred people that that you're
in touch with whether through family
networks or work however it is it is in
fact a very big deal how you operate and
lead right now and honestly I think this
is why my previous point number one is
so important because if you're all eaten
up with anxiety and frustration and rage
about things you can't control then
you're not in the right headspace or
heart space to actually love and lead
the people God has placed in front of
you so take radical responsibility for
yourself in your little corner of the
world and then leave the rest in God's
hands and honestly you just might find
that that this season the way you you
deal with it and and act and think
during it actually has ripple effects
for the years you have remaining because
the truth is that this virus it has
simply brought to the surface a weakness
in you and I that has always been there
this is need to control so let's let it
go and it's love and lead well in the
sphere God has given us so that's all
for today if you enjoy this video and
think others could benefit from it and
then please like it share it and to
ensure you don't miss any future
episodes go ahead and subscribe to my
youtube channel or my podcast most
anywhere podcasts are offered by
searching bretzel fir'd tabletalk grace
peace